días después de recibir el visto bueno
para montar sus puestos los comerciantes
cierran sus tiendas el aumento de los
casos de kobe no obliga a las
autoridades locales de múnich a cancelar
el mercado navideño de la ciudad por
segundo año consecutivo
hanson host datos ahora tenemos que
desmontar nuestros puestos y tenemos que
asumir todos los gastos nadie nos paga
los costes
de huntington ex alzas penal los
mercados navideños reciben el golpe
mientras los casos de kobe alcanzan otro
récord en alemania se han registrado más
de 65 mil nuevas infecciones en las
últimas 24 horas en muchas regiones el
acceso a la mayoría de establecimientos
incluidos bares cafés y gimnasios es
exclusivo de quienes se hayan vacunado o
sometido a pruebas
el jueves los diputados votaron a favor
de ampliar las restricciones de acceso
al transporte público la legislación
permitiría a los estados individuales
introducir más medidas dependiendo del
número de casos registrados a nivel
regional en un momento políticamente
delicado el proyecto de ley suscitó un
acalorado debate el gobierno saliente de
angela merkel va a ser sustituido por
una coalición de socialdemócratas verdes
y liberales proempresariales
el debate de hoy no es sobre los
conservadores o el gobierno entrante de
los distintos partidos se trata de
proteger nuestro país y para ello
estamos poniendo las medidas adecuadas
los conservadores amenazaron con
bloquear el proyecto de ley el viernes
cuando se someta a la consideración de
la cámara alta del parlamento por otra
parte el comité consejero de vacunas de
alemania ha recomendado la dosis anti
cobit de refuerzo para todos los mayores
de 18 años